have you heard the story of the guy bob
lazar
oh yeah what do you think about all that
i this is about him back engineering
these crap i mean he
vividly explains these things them
flying around like
zooming through this through the air
yeah so that and defying like what was
it the
the crafts could actually like fold
through gravity or something
so the whole the thing about babazar is
that
i do i think that he's brilliant i think
that he must be
a genius but his story doesn't
it doesn't line up over time not the
details of the story
but the circum the circumstantial
evidence of the story right
so he gets picked to be the guy to
reverse engineer alien technology
and then somehow he's also able to like
get free from the government and be
allowed to talk about
his history of doing this stuff right
the us government
would never bring in somebody even
remotely unstable to take on something
that sensitive
and if they did there would be all sorts
of legal documents and whatever else to
basically make sure that the guy
never saw the light of day if he became
unstable
they wouldn't like kill him or put him
in a cell they'd have like you have your
own island and bora bora and you're just
gonna live there and we're gonna take
care of all your needs that's what they
would do
yeah like they wouldn't disappear the
guy and put him in prison they'd pay a
fortune to make sure that
his secrets never get out right but this
whole idea that like
the government went out and like
publicly discredited him
because he's really a brilliant engineer
who can
you know reverse engineer alien
technology and there's nobody else out
there who can do it
i've seen enough spectacular people
right there's enough exceptional people
he's not that exceptional well first of
all what makes you say they'd put them
on
pay a fortune and put them on a remote
island and take care of him or do they
do that
they do that all the time they don't do
that to americans as often as they do
with the foreigners but they do it all
the time
really dude you can make a problem
disappear
for like the cia does that no this is
the us government can do this man
this when when witness protection is all
about making people disappear
by paying a fixed amount to basically
make them go live a very comfortable
life somewhere
where nobody can find them that is
witness protection
you get you amp that up and now you can
basically convince
foreign generals and foreign politicians
to work for
to work for the cia the nsa the dia you
name it
right and you're basically saying hey
we're just going to make you disappear
we're just going to take you to some
glorious private place in greece
no one's ever going to know you're there
you have a new identity and new
everything and we're going to take care
of all of your expenses for life
you've got kgb former kgb people living
in the united states
who basically signed a deal with cia to
say we'll rat out the kgb as long as you
let us have american citizenship and you
give us an american name and american
passport that happens all the time right
so as far as bob lazar's story goes like
he wasn't compromised until they were
spying on him this his story at least
goes
and they were spying on him they tapped
his phone lines they found out his wife
was cheating on him his wife was having
an affair
then they're like oh this is a ticking
time bomb as soon as he finds this out
he's going to be
unfit to do this job so then they
started phasing him out
and then he started making himself
public
he did the interviews he did uh i forget
the guy's name who did the interview
with
george knapp i think his name was and
then uh at that point
they tried to do many things like they
tried to hide
where he went to college or or like bury
his degree his college degree at least
according to the story
right according to his story so this is
this is the problem again we're going
back to that information knowledge
experience triangle
right single-sourced information one
person is saying this stuff right we
can't validate it any other way
right that immediately means that it
can't ever be knowledge single source
information just can't be knowledge it
can't be intel even if it's true
it has to be sourced and it has to be
vetted it has to be validated has to be
verified right or else
we don't know that it's true the best it
can be is just probable
right so then you have to look at the
content of the information itself
he is claiming stuff nobody else has
ever claimed
no weapons developer no other engineer
no nasa scientist
nothing right so how is single-sourced
information
so highly specific about like alien
technology
and you just as you watch over time you
can see the degradation
in the story itself like a cover story
it just degrades over time it doesn't
hold up
why would they be tapping his phones why
would they be tapping every part of his
life
if they trusted him enough to put him in
charge of the approach in the project in
the first place
it doesn't make any sense and then why
would they see his wife having an affair
as the thing that would make him
unstable like
how what would make them come to the
conclusion that he's going to connect
his wife's adultery
with then becoming unstable with this
program if he's so brilliant and so
genius
then very likely he probably wasn't
emotionally
attached enough to serve to keep his
marriage alive which is why it was
falling apart
like it just it doesn't match up well
even though he is a genius or you know
he seems to be
extremely intelligent in what he's do
and what he does
that doesn't necessarily mean that he's
as
emotionally intelligent exactly so if he
was to eventually catch his wife he
could completely unwind
why do we think that though if you think
that he's not emotionally intelligent
why would he have an emotional reaction
like that to
the the well it's not the integration of
that he wouldn't know how to he wouldn't
know how to handle it
like he wouldn't know how to handle
finding his wife cheating on him he
could
you know whatever start to abu you know
drink all the time or do drugs or
whatever and
and he just he he wouldn't be stable
that's true and it could also be
that it doesn't even phase him it could
also be that he's like
well i don't really hang out with my
wife anyways because i'm always in the
lab and
you know we're not really the same
person anyways right but it's tasty
it is a risk it is a risk well it's just
as much of a risk
as putting taps on a person against like
court orders anyways right
like there's so many what i'm getting at
is the only way you can connect the
story
is through a very specific set of points
that don't consider any alternatives as
soon as you start to connect
alternatives
the story starts to break down you're
like well it's not logical that this
would happen
if these other two things were possible
and then if
that still happened like if the
probability still happened
then it still isn't logical that this
next thing would happen so how many
illogical steps have to happen before we
start to ask ourselves like well
maybe the whole story is just illogical
maybe the guy just lives in like
never neverland maybe he really was
working on some super cool stuff
but it wasn't actually alien maybe the
guy was working on some super cool stuff
that the government told him was alien
because they
didn't want him to know anything else
like who knows any number of
any number of viable alternative stories
could happen
in addition to his story but what's hard
here is that because he's been saying
his story for so long he's been
interviewed so many times and the ufo
community is such a dedicated such a
passionate community
they want to believe that other life is
out there just like they also want to
believe that it's friendly and they also
want to believe that it's intelligent
they also want to believe that it's
humanoid and they also want to believe
that it's
visible right nobody's going to feel
very good
if they find out that real aliens are
actually like
the size of other planets and could
basically crush us
accidentally like nobody's going to want
to believe that
yeah or that there's some kind of like
spiritual entity that's just made of
energy
and they basically have the ability to
wipe our brains like nobody wants to
think any negative stuff about it
they want to believe that it's something
that they can put into their little
their their conventions of science
fiction
it's not it's going to be much bigger
than that if he did have
first if what he says is true and he was
working on some sort of crazy craft that
works like nothing
we've ever seen before and uses
technology that we've never we can't
even comprehend
is it is it true that the government
would want to keep
keep it under wraps specifically for
um keeping us protected against other
countries and threats from other
countries like that we don't
we don't want other countries to know
that we have this because we want to use
this for
for weaponization or yeah most likely
if what he was saying is true the most
likely outcome would be that we would
siphon off little pieces that we
understand
and use them to advance ourselves right
it's the same thing that
it's like it's why nasa existed for so
long because they created little things
that were useful in space that then
could also be used in everyday life
so that if for weaponization for
urbanization for industrial purposes for
any number of reasons right and to keep
it out of the hands of adversaries for
sure
if what he was saying is true most
likely we would take what we understand
and siphon it off
it would never go into some black vault
to never see the light of day again
because that's just a risk putting it in
a black vault where nobody ever gets to
see it
is just an invitation for someone else
to steal that information
and then use it against you so we would
never do that we would take what we know
and we would start to build on it and
apply it and
use it to evolve ourselves as fast as we
could
that's just human nature that's that's
survival instinct